mein vorname ist lukas meine lieben
freunde habt euch mal wieder zahlreich
gewünscht und leider hab ich euch heute
herzlich willkommen heißen zu endlich
mal wieder einer neuen episode ich
reagiere auf luca minis
wenn mich jemand fragt ob ich für den
test gelernt habe und ich nicht mal
wusste dass wir einen test schreiben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das fast meine komplette schulzeit
relativ gut zusammen diese eine tante
bei familienfeiern
[Musik]
ich glaube jeder hat seine tante wie ich
all meinen freunden beziehungstipps gebe
obwohl ich selbst der größte single des
jahrhunderts miteinander vorbeigeredet
wieder eine parade beispiel schlechthin
für missachtete kommunikationswege ja
ich bin tatsächlich auch
hundertprozentig ich um 9 uhr morgens
wenn man die letzte nacht richtig
gefeiert hat sorry nachbarn nicht noch
mal
englisch
natürlich sehe ich mich in
ich will nicht so tun wie wenn ich nicht
wüsste wovon ein crash redet obwohl ich
ihn die ganze letzte nach gestoppt habe
hallo ach so ja
freunde ich würde sagen wir packen die
video - jetzt beiseite und kommen normal
wieder zu den normalen bilder - von
daher machen direkt mit diesem hier wenn
du kontakt zu greifen die stecken
wer hat euch verarscht leute mein bester
freund ist der spiegel er hat noch nie
gelacht als ich geweint habe brauche es
ist halt auch ein spiegel 1 habe ich in
mathe gelernt wenn es so einfach geht
ist es falsch dass die wahrheit
es ist auch wieder so eine sache die mir
in der schulzeit aufgefallen ist wie
heißen die klügsten ende studie
[Musik]
warum unangenehme telefonate sollte man
immer mit ich muss auflegen die schaukel
wird frei beenden
was das für eine schaukel denn sandy bei
ihrer ausbildung mittagspause hand warum
habt ihr so viel freizeit dass ihr diese
ganzen - machen könnt tankwarte sie
tanken gerade super diesel fahrer danke
ich frage mich wirklich wo ich hier
gelandet bin 10 uhr ein uhr 4 uhr auch
ich acht minuten von meinem termin ja
das bin dann wohl leider auch wieder ich
eltern wenn man sie fragt ob man bei
mcdonald's essen gehen kann wir haben
den ganzen gefrierschrank voll und
werden jetzt sicherlich nicht von
mcdonald's anhalten ja klassisch ist
auch immer die typische hey wir haben
noch brot zu hause wir fahren jetzt
nichts macdonald mein handy ist so oft
an der steckdose das ist eigentlich mein
haus telefon sagte hu
das ist auch wieder die wahrheit was
heißt sonnenuntergang auf finnisch
chelsea
[Musik]
hat euch noch mainz den gestoßen wird es
vielleicht was versuchen irgendwie raus
zu holen habe luca bei der aufnahme
gesehen und auch ein foto gebeten
witzig wie nennt man einen schlauen
modedesigner jean
[Musik]
dummheit wenn du etwas verloren hat und
jemand dich fragte wo du es verloren
hast das stimmt auch wieder
es ist genauso wie wenn leute meine
freundin hat sich von mir getrennt sie
meint ich trainiere zu viel hat vor wut
erstmal ihren smart in die nordsee
geworfen wer das ist dann das wenn dann
würde ich mit meinen muskeln halten was
ist der unterschied zwischen kostenlos
und umsonst meine schulbildung war
kostenlos deine umsonst an rahmen
für dich was ist die größte brauerei der
welt deutschland mit 80 millionen
flaschen auf front decker dieser moment
wenn man sich gibt schild vor den
fernseher setzen und eine plötzlich
einfällt dass man morgen eine
mathearbeit schreibt das ist wahr das
ist einfach wahr
einfach war dieser moment wenn in der
schule die anwesenheit kontrolliert wird
und du dich vorher nervös auf das jahr
vorbereitet das stimmt auch
kennt ihr das auch wenn man sich zum
neuen leuten vorstellen konzentriert
sich so sehr darauf die man wirkt auf
diese leute und auf den handschlag und
weiter und so fort dass man innerhalb
von einer sekunde den namen vergisst
habe ich auch jedes mal die deutsche
sprache ist sehr kompliziert wenn man
einen einzigen buchstaben verdreht ist
der satz dominiert das stimmt auch
wieder ich habe mit der pflanze
ausgemacht sie nur noch einmal im monat
zu gießen wie es darauf eingegangen
alter wer was habt ihr in eurer wenn mir
jemand erzählt dass er mit offener tür
oder offenen schrank schwebt
ja
stelle auch wieder sandra wie geht das
solide und luca blogs
ja
das ist auch wieder die wahrheit ich
schlafe im sommer mit offenem fenster
57.000 mücken freuen sich das stimmt
auch wieder welche sprache spricht man
in der sauna schwitzen ihr diese
dummheit wenn du merkst du dass du
single bist ja ich jetzt schon seit mehr
als einem halben jahr will come to my
life wenn zahnärzte durch uns geld
verdienen wie so empfehlen sie uns dann
gute zeit leute die sagen man soll sich
nicht über kleinigkeiten aufregen hat
mit sicherheit noch nie eine mücke im
zimmer ich gestern 8
ganz schlimm ich habe hier ein
mückenstich da wir hier an meine
arschbacken wenn ich nach einem netz
erst mal wieder auf mein leben
klarkommen muss es stimmt
hier ist es wohl häufiger zum beispiel
gestern zum letzten mal nett gemacht
einfach auch wieder wegen pollenallergie
ich kam überhaupt nicht klar allerdings
habe ich gestern gemacht und ich bin
danach aufgebracht ich hab' ich habe nur
billig
wie spätestens 18 jahrhundert ich muss
zum sport dieser moment kurz bevor man
niesen muss dieser moment wenn du nur
einen screenshot machen willst und
einfach aus versehen dein handy ausmaß
passiert wie immer oder kennt ihr das
wenn ihr euer handy einfach nur
entspannen wollte klickt auf den knopf
an der seite aber macht automatisch
direkten screenshot ich bin der einzige
kugel kannst du nicht weißt wer die
schönste person auf der welt ist dies
das zweite wort noch mal und das dritte
du nicht habt humor studiert glaube ich
freuen doppelpunkt ey kommen sei nicht
traurig omg danke hat mir jetzt mega
geholfen und jetzt geht es mir wieder
mega kannst du auch noch mehr mega
vielleicht auch einschreiben mega gut
mega unterscheidet mich dass heute
wieder ist allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde ich werde täglich auf
zahlreichen luca - auf instagram
markiert also wenn ihr wollt dass ihr
auch heuer mit in die nächsten rennen
wenn ich noch mal auf luca - und dann
wollt ihr dann instagram markiert mich
hoch und haben video wenn es euch
gefallen hat